okay someone help me out what's an
example and I want some working here
please so my working how am I going to
do kind of like the same sort of
algebraic game here in order to get
something I can work with you understand
ok so I'm going to go 1 2 x minus x
squared minus do you want me to do minus
one plus one not that the one that is
all that much ok so what do I do with
this ok now i'm going to say first it's
not a perfect square yeah because I've
got a minus sign out the front of that x
squared so I guess it's like a negative
square and kind of but to make that
clear underneath my square root I'm
going to write about the one at the
front which is what i'm expecting to be
like the standard for my one needs a in
this case the pastas latest it doesn't
matter but i want a squared minus x
squared not the other end so that's what
I'm going to put this positive 1 gonna
stick it out in front take away I'm
going to slap around some big brackets
which will resolve my negative for my
excrement so that gives me this and now
the perfect square is a little clearer
okay so now I'll write it in its
factorized form which is what sweat and
this is my standard form I could go
ahead and I could write this opposition
if I want but it's simple enough that i
think i'm just going to go for ok that
make sense def just 0
so glad you asked I'm so glad just so so
so um not quite I wasn't going to
conclude where you did but let's see if
I can tease it out what chance is
referring to is the fact that when you
got squares here right um X minus 1
square because it removes the sign
because where is the same as 1 minus X
square did you notice that okay so that
looks kind of weird though because if I
proceeded from there you would think
like that doesn't that kind of
significantly change what's happening
here and the answer is it does but watch
out when you go ahead and do this all
right you can't simply write down butter
and have 1 minus X instead now you see
this is why you don't trust yourself
right watch what happens when I do the
necessary thing to change the actual
variable of integration because we're
really doing the first table if I said
let u equal 1 and take away x and then I
say well I better change into to use so
i go ahead and do this but of course the
answer here is there you've won right
and so to compensate over there if I
want to stick on one in so it substitute
for a 1 there really needs to be a minus
sign that comes along for the ride does
that make sense so really if I do the
substitution properly I'm going to have
minus to you on 1 minus so it's just
that you see now so that minus sign just
kind of hangs around and does its thing
this is sine inverse of you which is one
minus X I'll see but of course sign of
us is what kind of function it's on so
therefore I'm going to get sine inverse
halt X minus 1 because of the concentric
hey does that make sense
was yeah so I was your magic like
cigarette though oh sure I searched me
yeah so if i say go from this guy i can
say as you know because the gradients
are just off by a new sign this is going
to be cos inverse of omega 1 minus X
right plus C but I think big right
what's the difference between this and
this can we think about what these
things look like right we know what
regular sign in versus wrong color
regular sign in mass is going to look
like this yeah happy with that so what's
an investor x minus one looks like where
does it go it's a shift in what
direction it's a shift on the air so
it's clearly horizontal it's gone that
way okay so being that my boundaries
here and here are negative one and one
the new boundaries will be 0 and 2 so
I'm going to come over to here there you
go so that's what this is telling me
okay what about this ago okay this is a
bit icky and you see what's going on
right i'm going to rewrite it to make it
a little clearer because not only is
there a shift right but there's also
this reflection and we've seen before
how easy is to confuse them because they
affect each other right a better way to
write this would be to say it's cos
inverse of negative x minus 1 I think
that's a better way right plus my
constant of course so what does this
thing with either space what does
regular cos inverse look like it's a
going to be up here right yeah that's
where he usually is okay so what's this
telling me to do
okay so if I reflect it's going to come
down to hold on across the across the
y-axis which is horizontal it's going to
look like that and then I do my one
shift over to the Holland up that late
yeah yeah because he has a near-constant
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah close enough so here
we are over here right but of course if
I want this to be exactly abortion as
you melaquin exactly equal to the one
that I got over here I would just add
what would i subtract rather or when i
subtract pile too so that's kind of
included in here whatever that happens
to be okay does that make sense and i
would give it to their or i would give
it to both equipment okay